hey Graham how you going mate good how
are you
have you been having a good conference
so far I have an absolute ball May and
look it I cannot believe all these
people have chosen the others over Troy
home ah yeah this is just like chosen
the wrong session well it only beers
actually it's gonna be awesome
hey I've been numb I've been thinking
about doing a new startup okay and and
and bear with me all right some idea is
I'm gonna do machine learning and
service block chain for your frigerator
dice dispersal so odd but I'm gonna call
it internet of things as well no no no
no I'm I'm gonna call it the ice cream
van bought the ice cream what can i I've
been writing some code that I really
quite excited about yeah and and I
really respect your opinion so I knew if
I could show it to you get some feedback
is that okay look yeah I'd love to I
actually I really like looking at
people's code I find it's a really good
way to sort of learn new techniques new
things so yeah bring it up that's yeah
well Simon random unit says unit tests
are awesome man right very brilliant
yeah I love unit tests TDD all those
kind of techniques really helped me like
load nice so this is the this is one of
the tests that I've been writing I'm
just want to like what you think mate
all right cool let's let's have a look
so I'll just give me a sec another scan
through okay so so you okay if I give
you a bit of kind of feedback on what
I'm seeing here comments and still
absolutely so I really like the way
you're using a range act and assert to
lay out this code I think that's a
really really nice technique because it
makes it really obvious when I'm looking
at it where you're saying up your state
what is it you're actually trying to do
in your act part and then I can see what
you're expecting to happen in the assert
so really like I always use Triple A
it's awesome triple A's cool yeah it's
really really good so yeah okay are you
okay if I give you some kind of comments
where I think you know we could maybe
change things make yeah that'd be great
all right cool so let's have a quick
look through so we can see here we've
got
mock ice cream price calculator top top
returns okay customer provided by my
name
customers got a balance there's an ice
ice cream van so you're writing software
for an ice cream van right yeah the ice
cream van bought
it's coming into the right time of year
so that's cool it's kind of nice and
warm out there in Sydney it's gonna be
warming perf I think this weekend and
probably a good time to buy ice cream so
we're gonna try and sell Graham a Chop
top yep so that's pretty cool then we're
gonna check the customer yen we're going
to check they've received their type of
chop tarp and we're going to check their
balance all right so there's a lot of
more objects in here right you like my
cops I love mark objects I use them for
everything it's all semantics really
okay right right
so you okay if I share a few kind of war
stories I've had with mock object
begrimed here cuz you know I used to use
them a lot as well but I find that I
don't use them nearly as often as I use
kay okay
they'll take you back like six or seven
years I was working on a system in Perth
as she writing a secondhand trading
system and we had a lot of code like
this scared for our application so all
our tests had this kind of same arranged
act assert with democ do you have this
code copied in a lot of places as well
yeah I probably got about 30 tests to
look reasonably similar with some of the
different variations yeah right okay
yeah so we have a very similar situation
we had about 3000 but most of them had a
kind of block of mock setup code like
this and yeah Wow okay um I found a few
issues which have kind of scared me away
from using them so you look at that cell
method down there yeah right so I know I
can see that we're trying to sell gram
of Chop top but I can tell from these
mock objects exactly what methods you
expect to be called when you're inside
that cell method right yep so what I
found is that that's kind of really
coupling this test to the actual
implementation of the code that you're
writing behind it okay does that kind of
make sense yeah I can see that your cell
code is expecting all these particular
things
yeah like find by name and go yeah right
right so what happened for me was across
my 3,000 tests one very common method
that most of my tests ended up in a
change implementation and boom I broke
about a thousand tests in 1,000 tests
and now that you mention it sometimes I
do break like lots of tests all at the
same time right right okay worse still
because that code was duplicated
everywhere I had to go through all of
the methods that actually changed them
and add the new mock call in there so
it's a bit of a nightmare it took us a
few days to actually do
across the team yeah it was a I found
that you know that that brittle kind of
coupling between the actual tests what
we're trying to test and the
implementation was really really hard
work and we're still it actually made us
quite reluctant to try refactorings
going forward because we just knew that
every time we changed the internals of
our domain we'd have this huge knock-on
effects on our test case it kind of
became unmaintainable so we had this
kind of light bulb moment I saw it for
watching a talk a few years ago and I've
sort of switched from having my unit
test testing the implementation of the
code to be much more behavioral focused
so the thing here is that I don't really
want my unit test to care about how the
internals of my methods are implemented
I want to try and test the behaviors
without coupling myself in that way
interesting so yeah what would that look
like
should we do some virtual kind of coding
on the fly here it's just in paper it's
kind of you imagine a keyboard here
let's get going ok cool so let's have
all that what a class now you've got to
kind of you know you could be a little
bit surprised when you see some of this
stuff so let's you know let's just kind
of go for it bit by bit also see how we
end up so we're going to keep the test
of range in the same way right so we're
going to have the triple a syntax still
yep gonna keep it very very similar
because that's that's really good so
let's set up some data
okay so interesting yeah so in the
original test class we were relying on
mock objects really heavily at this
point of our range test whereas what
we're gonna do here is actually create
real objects behind the scenes so these
are our main classes yeah we're not
using marks so you can imagine for
example when we're hitting save on one
of these I will talk about object mover
and things like that later but this is
kind of using pre cans objects that are
correctly set up they've got stay
attached to the met cetera and we can
twiddle them a little bit you can see
Graham there's got a balance yeah ten
down there but we're gonna save them and
that could be in a real database it
could be in like an in-memory database
or something like that okay but the
point is we're trying to make this test
kind of not so concerned about what's
going on behind the scenes so we just
want to self to stay at the system okay
cuz let's go through the act bit then
okay what's this resolve here resolve
yeah right so I mean you've probably
come across resolve when you're dealing
with things like IOC containers right
yeah okay so that's what I use oh yeah
all spikes cool right so I remember in
the last test we actually nude up the
service at this point
and we passed it in the mock objects
right well that kind of coupled us to
the actual constructor of that object as
well so there's all these little
couplings going on it's a good point
because actually whenever I add a new
item to the constructor that breaks all
my tests I've to go on yeah exactly that
okay so in this way we're going to kind
of get a few things for free here we're
going to use resolve which means we're
using a real ioc container that's being
wired up with the real services as well
and it's using the real ioc
configuration so we're testing a bit
more production doing ice but it means
that if we start adding these extra
parameters to the ice cream van it's not
really gonna concern is that much
because we don't need to worry about
that here we're just exhibiting this
behavior which is selling a Chop top to
Gram okay what does the assert section
look like yeah let's have a look shall
we
so this is really straightforward so
again if you remember in your code that
you showed me earlier you were again
sort of using mocks for all parts of
this so you were making sure that
certain methods have been called on
collections and things like there I'm
just looking at a collection here and
I'm saying hey look grams ice creams do
they have a top top inside them okay and
the balance it's just a number let's
just check that it's the right number
after we've done the behavior now if I
forgot and refactor that cell method
you'd see that I wouldn't actually be
changing any of this test because the
behavior of selling an ice cream doesn't
change that often right but I should be
free it will so go and refactor it and I
think this kind of makes that a little
bit easier going forward this is really
interesting I'm like you know I love
doing TDD and but what we were just
testing there is multiple classes
together yeah we all know that when
we're doing TDD we're doing unit tests
and unit tests so when you test a single
method on a single class right and you
walk everything out so anymore sorry so
this go back up a little bit so you said
that a unit test is testing like a
single method on a on a single class
right okay that's that's really
interesting where did you hear that
everyone everyone knows that you know
like Kent Beck and all of that sort of
stuff okay all right okay ah look I mean
I have to admit I used to do this as
well and I would mock out all the
collaborators because the unit was the
unit and that was the method or the
class price right yeah so then I watched
a video by a guy called Ian Cooper a few
years ago he did a talk called TDD where
did it all go wrong really recommend you
go and watch it so yeah great great talk
and
taught me a lot about how I do my
testing today but more importantly it
may be gone pick up the book I forgot to
bring it with me I can only have it in
my bag but I believe me this time but
anyway I've gone through that book from
front to back and one thing's really
interesting because Ken always refers to
a unit as a unit of behavior not an
actual method on a class really yeah and
it's just one of those things that kind
of people drop the behavior bit and just
kind of decided that the unit was the
smallest thing that you could possibly
test interesting but yeah the book kind
of always talks about a unit of behavior
so it's kind of one of those cases Heon
had a really good quote actually from
the video that he had a test case per
class approach fails to capture the
ethos for TDD adding a new class is not
the trigger for writing tests the
trigger is implemented in requirement or
a behavior the little classes and things
that drop out of that should probably
come from your refactorings that you do
later because again it's a great talk
but it's okay to test you know more than
one thing together I think yeah and guys
together so I guess we're talking about
testing behavior we're talking about
testing you know multiple classes are
you saying that we should just write
your why test for everything then and
and just test the system from there oh
right okay I hadn't kind of gone to that
logical conclusion I guess as you start
sort of going up the abstraction scale
you do hit UI test eventually don't you
yeah look I'm not saying we shouldn't
write UI tests but I guess I should say
we have to be a bit careful where we
decide to use your eye test okay can I
give you a couple more stories yeah
that'd be awesome I love because I've
been I've kind of been bitten by your
eye test a little bit in the past so
it's actually the same project that I
was working on luckily there's no one in
here working on that project I did this
talk in person people were kind of
glaring at me so we had a project that
had about 300 UI tests right okay and
they all took about 20 seconds to run so
there yeah so the first thing that we
noticed is that as we wanted to go
faster and deploy faster we were relying
on these tests for a lot of our
confidence in regression so that meant
that we had to weigh and we had to have
a green run to go into production with
them and they were taking about three
and a half hours to run by the time I
left so that became like a real barrier
to actually deploying quickly so that
was the first problem
I fan with them they're not Tory ously
brittle
I mean you've probably seen this right
I've you've written you itis before yeah
they are a bit of a pain yeah yeah you
know you change your UI slightly if you
don't have your test laid out properly
then that could cause it to break really
easily
um then you get the kind of intermittent
failures as well let's say you didn't
quite put the fredbot sleep right or you
haven't waited for a piece of your UI to
update that's one of those where you've
got to try and get on to that and fix it
because if you don't fix these UHS
quickly then they tend to sort of start
dying as a whole and before you know it
you've got a suite of 300 tests and half
of just read permanently but you still
go alive because you lose all your
confidence in them yeah okay keeping on
them like that though is really hard
work because they take a lot of time to
look after them and maintain them so we
had a rule as a team that we were not
allowed to start working in the morning
until we'd investigated any of our
failing UI tests okay so it took us a
long time but we started to get a little
bit better and a bit more confident in
them I had one really funny one cuz it
kind of give you like a hilarious yeah
it wasn't hilarious at the time we were
kind of tearing our hair out how do you
I test and it felt over a period of
about six months Wow work out what was
going on with this test and we had a
test a UI test it was driving an
analysis query behind the scenes okay so
what we found out in the end was that
the UI was being exercised really
quickly because it was automated so it's
click click click click click all the
events were getting raised and every so
often that audit crew wouldn't work like
the aggregate data that came out was
just wrong the test failed and it took
us a while before we realize what was
going on and under occasional
circumstances maybe if you're lucky once
every three or four days the test would
run at a certain time and the virtual
machine that was actually writing out
that audit events would resynchronize
its clock and when it resynchronized its
clock it went back about naught point
two of a second in time and because we
were flying events through it so quickly
back not point two seconds put one event
that should have always followed the
original event behind the original event
which actually broke the analysis query
Wow
through virtual machine clock syncs now
am I saying really hard it was horrible
yeah I will never get that time back in
my life right it's gone dusted I'm I'm
43 now so
you know how I wish I could have that
time back man that sounds awfully
painful so like yeah so you know you eye
tests whoa so what I'm getting from that
is like UI tests are really painful we
should just not write your chest at all
whenever I I wouldn't say that no I
think that we have to think a little bit
more pragmatically about when we use UI
tests oh hello my name is Rob Moore and
I'm Graham Foster and today we're going
to be talking to you about advanced
testing techniques the conversation that
you just witnessed between us is one
that we've both had or a similar
conversation many times with many people
from many companies over many years and
it provides a lot of great context for
what we're going to be discussing today
now the things that we're talking about
today are essentially an amalgamation of
thinking and and mindset and practices
and techniques that we've developed over
the last few years that we've found to
be highly effective in software testing
that we do so let's do a quick recap of
that first 15 minutes I think I would
argue it's more important and useful to
test the behavior of our classes over
the actual implementation detail it's
easier to write the tests I find and
it's less rittle and easier to refactor
going forwards I think it's important
that we get across to a unit at a unit
test is not necessarily a method or a
class a unit is a unit of behavior and
that can involve multiple classes
collaborating with each other going on
from that a lot of people will talk
about integration tests and a lot of
people say that an integration test is
about testing multiple classes together
I would disagree with that personally I
think an integration test is where we
have disparate systems and we want to
make sure that all those systems can
communicate with each other so I'm okay
to call an integration test that but for
me all unit tests can be working with
multiple classes and UI testing is
useful but I think it's very very
fragile and we should use it judiciously
absolutely so I guess the question is
how do we test behavior we've got a
little bit of an inkling as to how we
might do it through the pair programming
exercise that we did with origami and
there's a few things to talk about here
because if you think about a range act
assert in a test where we're testing
behavior the code that we're testing in
act is a lot more complicated
then it might be for a more traditional
implementation focused unit test so you
know there's a lot more complexity there
and by association often the data that
we have to set up in the arrange section
is going to be more complex and then the
things that we're actually asserting on
at the end are also more complex now
what this means is that we have to use
techniques to deal with that complexity
because if we don't and we've used the
proaches that we've always used we're
going to be in for a world of pain it's
not gonna be a very pleasant experience
now for us the way that this manifests I
guess is a mindset of treating test code
like production code we should be
refactoring our test code we should be
using patterns in our test code so over
the next few minutes we'll cover some of
the patterns and the techniques that we
use and that we find highly effective
for testing behavior first one of these
is something called subcutaneous tests
now subcutaneous is a medical term it
means under the skin and the
subcutaneous best is probably best
explained through a diagram like this
the basic idea is we're trying to skip
that UI layer that as we've already
discussed is typically very slow and
very fragile to test and then go in just
below that so it might be like an MVC
controller or an mvvm view or if you're
using something like C Kuras it might be
a commander or a query or something like
that and then we have our full
production code underneath typically
powered by our production ioc container
and any databases or data sources that
are owned and sort of completely
isolated or within our our system we
actually hook them up as well because
they're not external to our system
they're part of our system they're part
of our unit of behavior the one thing we
do do though is that we isolate any
external systems and we mock them out
because we're not trying to do an
end-to-end test or an integration test
those are still useful but by doing that
we would be adding some that slowness
and fragility that we're trying to avoid
in this style of testing and we found
that subcutaneous testing is a highly
effective way of writing unit tests
against the system that are reasonably
fast but allow us to test a behavior
rather than implementation detail
awesome so I want to think a little bit
about when we're writing a test how do
we side which type of tests to run
because we have this subcutaneous test
and we do still have sort of lower-level
unit tests which which may have some
value in certain situations now going
back to include his talk he has this
really great analogy he refers to it as
shifting gears so who who's got a manual
car in here it's not many of ours in
Europe you might even pause right
everywhere over there yeah but you know
think of your car it's got a gear stick
right so when we write in a subcutaneous
test where we're really just testing the
behavior we've picked up a feature it's
pretty clear how we're going to develop
it there's nothing new in there we're in
sixth gear fifth gear I don't know top
gear whatever your car is we're going
we're speeding down the highway we can
just write a sub-q test it's pretty easy
we can use that object from others and
the test data builders to create our set
up data and just do nice assertions at
the end so all good move along sometimes
though we come across something that's a
little bit trickier so maybe like you're
working in a trading environment or
something like that and you've got to
implement some complex financial
algorithms down there you might find
that a behavioral test at that high
level is kind of almost too high up to
start working out how to implement that
algorithm so this is Ian's analogy of
shifting gears going down the stack so
it's almost like as we start dropping
down the gears we're starting to isolate
more and more of it what it is we're
trying to test by mocking out more and
more collaborators so the very lowest
level where we're literally back at the
mock objects with just testing a little
bit behavior subbing out all the
collaborators now once you've got this
test is a couple of important things I
think that you want to bear in mind the
first is that you still want that
behavioral test which is covering this
code path because that's still a very
important test it's kind of easy to
reason with if it's easy to read to read
and it's going to be easier to maintain
so you've got the code pass covered so
you have to decide whether you want to
actually keep these low-level tests or
delete them so I'll say it's okay in
some situations to go and delete tests
okay do that but there's a few things
you might want to think about before you
decide whether or not to delete it
the first is let's say you get new
people coming onto your team those a
low-level test could actually be really
useful to work out how something was
implemented or why it was implemented in
that way so there could be users kind of
a learning exercise so that's one
possible reason you might want to
eat them but again they're going to be
brittle they're going to inhibit you
from refactoring that code later on and
because they're covered by a behavior
test you can make that decision within
your team whether or not to keep it or
to delete them what other reason they
all go it's like a clash song the other
reason why you might want to sorry there
is no you why you might want to not
delete them is if you needed that low
level of tests to actually design that
really complex code in the first place
then when you're maintaining the code
you might still need them to sort of
understand it when you dig in yep
absolutely cool nice ok so who here does
red green refactor who does red green
red green factor who does red red green
tractor it's kind of bit like that so
what I'm doing red green refights that I
guess traditionally what I would do is I
would write a failing test and I was
quite good at writing my failing test
writers came back said right a red test
and then he said make the test go green
now I guess the bit that I kind of
muddled up a little bit was when I made
the test go green I kind of made the
test go agreeing with really beautiful
code there's the code that I always
dreamed of it had all the power had my
Gogh book next to me I got design
patterns next to me I am gonna make that
test green but it's going to be
beautiful by the time I've finished that
bit of code now I've called this
liberated red green refactor and again
it's going back to the TDD where did it
all go wrong video because the in Cooper
makes a call out in that where he says
that actually red green refactor is
really three separate steps for a reason
so our brain struggles to work in two
different modes at the same time and if
we try and make beautiful code when we
try and make that test go green we're
kind of almost pitching it against
itself because one half is just
interested in solving the problem
whereas the other half is trying to make
it pretty and elegant so I challenge you
the next time you're writing a the green
portion of your test to use the most
horrible dirty disgusting columns they
just possibly go that far but don't
think about design patterns literally
write a transaction script it's okay
because your brain is going to work
better just trying to make that
go green now this has got some really
nice benefits because we're not going to
forget the refactor stage and just leave
the code like that right because that
would be a really really awful thing to
do for the rest of our teammates instead
we're going to use that refactor stage
to actually move to all of the nice
elegant design patterns that we want
inside our code base a couple of
interesting things though when we're
doing refactorings at this stage we're
not adding new behavior the behavior is
already covered by the tests so there is
no reason to test the refactor code in
any different way we don't need new
tests for it and that refactored code
quite often shows up as internals or
privates inside the modules because we
don't need to expose it to the outside
world it's already tested by the
behavior test and that's the important
part of it so next time you're going
from green red to green think awful code
and then refactor after that it's a
really really nice mindset to be in I
find nice so we talked about how there's
a lot more complexity when we're testing
behavior in each of the three sort of
stages of your tests and we start with
the arranged section we need to create
more complex data structures there's two
fairly well known patterns object mother
and test data builder that exists in the
ecosystem and they are highly effective
we've had a lot of success I guess in
combining them together
and rather going than going into that in
detail and you saw a little code snippet
when we did the pair programming but
that link there goes to a talk that I
did at ANZ decoders a couple of years
back that where I go in detail about the
pros and cons of each of those two
patterns and also the pros and cons of
combining them and a little bit of a
deep dive into some of the code to
actually implement that so I'll leave
that with you but then if we look at the
act section as we said there's there's
more complex code that we're actually
testing and one of the things that we do
with subcutaneous tests is we actually
mock out the external systems now
there's a beautiful pattern called
VCR pattern that really helps us with
this so if if we were say we were
talking to ten different external
systems over a number of different tests
if we were to try to hand roll all of
this sort of let's say it's a HTTP API
we're going to hand roll all the JSON
response
that get returned be really tedious to
set that up but the beautiful thing
about the VCR pattern is we can insert
that as a cross-cutting concern flip
switch and then all of the calls
actually get made to the real systems
returning the real responses except they
get stashed away in the file system and
committed into source control and then
we flip the switch back and what happens
is from then on those sort of stashed
mock respect so those stashed responses
get returned in a sort of mocked fashion
so this is very quick to set up
but then the great thing is if any of
our API contracts change with any of our
dependencies we can flip the switch
again rerun all the tests they might
take a little bit longer and there might
be a little bit more brittle for that
test run but you know you just do it a
couple of times you'll get the new
responses on your file system you can
commit those new responses flip the
switch again and then they've all been
updated very quick very easy so it's a
really nice pattern to you know to
quickly set up those external dependency
marks and that's your quick question on
that yes do you need the Betamax video
interestingly from memory one of them
it's been ported to many languages the
original implementations in Ruby I think
one of the ports was called Betamax I
could be wrong right but it might oh
yeah just something exactly my head
tells me that one of them was Betamax
and then if we look at the assert
section there's an incredibly powerful
technique that we use quite a lot called
approval tests the JavaScript ecosystems
decided to call them snapshot tests for
various reasons and the way that this
works is we're essentially using the
human brain as an assertion mechanism
that sounds very fancy these are the
human brain is an assertion making I did
do you like plug in sort of plug into
the computer running the test thankfully
no we don't need to do that no humans
are harmed in the making like this talk
and the basic way that this works is you
will give some sort of complex structure
so it might be a bunch of JSON or XML
that you pass to an end point or might
the HTML email you're sending to a
customer or you know it could be a
complex object structure that you've
turned into JSON and then you want to
check that it's the same as you expect
it to be and the basic way that it works
is that when the
a change to it you have a diff window
pop-up on your machine you can manually
inspect what it looks like and approve
it and then that gets stashed into the
file system and committed to source
control and will run on your computer
other dev machines and also the CI
server and if there's a difference
between what's generated and what was
stashed on the filesystem then the test
fails now it's kind of hard to describe
that in words and and it might be a bit
fuzzy for some of you so let's have a
look at an actual example so this is
some code that's quite similar to some
code that I wrote a few years back in
the telecommunications context so
essentially we're setting up a you know
shopping cart of some sort we've got NBN
VoIP and an international calls bonus
option we've got the arrange act to cert
in this case given when then that's the
same thing it's a subcutaneous test
against you know some sort of MVC
controller a check out controller so
we're going to execute the index action
which is posting to the checkout and
then this here is where we're doing our
assertion we grab out the mock
provisioning system from our CR from our
ioc container and we pull out the
request that should be in there from
that checkout having been posted and
then we've got this magic line at the
end should match approved and that's all
we need that's kind of crazy but let's
look at an example using so any assert
statements at that point in time
checking for different properties and
things absolutely right so in this
example let's say I've done some some
coding maybe I was a bit tired I didn't
do a very good job of it and so this is
what I get now we can say here this is
the the JSON payload that sent to the
provisioning system that sets up the MDM
and the VoIP and the phone line all
those sorts of things now we can see
here our international calls bonus
option has actually disappeared so I've
done something very wrong there and we
can see here that the work phone is now
actually the same as the home phone
rather than what it should have been so
I've obviously made a couple of mistakes
here in this instance but the great
thing about this is I can look at it and
the context is there I can immediately
see what I've done wrong I messed up the
where clause on the link expression and
when I rewrote that mapping code I
clearly used the wrong dot on the
intellisense for the work phone there so
I can instantly know where I need to go
and fix that code it's very quick you
just said that
normally you know India in the past
you'd have lots and lots of asserts for
something like this maybe you'd have one
per per property so you don't put 50 you
know 20 50 a cert something like that in
that instance if one of them goes wrong
I'm looking at a line number and I'm
like looking down and it's like you know
the the work phone you know and and and
I can't immediately see what's wrong
there it's gonna take me a lot longer to
actually diagnose what's wrong yeah
if you've got one assert per method if
you're kind of in that sort of
enterprise where they have this has
actually saved my bacon in other ways as
well like I've had a situation where one
of these complex data objects we've
added another object to it and there's
somebody forgot to go and put some
asserts on that object its forgot its
existence and then you're not actually
the test is still passing even though
you're breaking those properties whereas
this kind of is future proofing that
when you add model objects they just pop
up instantly so it's obvious that
something's changed on that structure so
it's really really powerful it works for
images as well right
yeah good point yes it does yeah so yeah
incredibly powerful technique highly
recommend you use it now let's take a
step back we've been talking about
testing behavior but in in reality we're
actually talking about something a
little bit different a little bit
broader and something that we call
pragmatic testing and the basic idea
behind it is when you're writing a test
or deciding that you want to write a
test of what kind of test you want to
write you should actually rather than
going well this is the way we've always
done it like a little sheep or you know
I'm gonna write this test because I'm
writing a test or whatever it might be
we actually stop and think about the
test that we're writing and the context
within we're writing it and make a
decision about does this test deliver me
value is it giving me confidence or some
other thing that is actually valuable to
me and my team now there's a really
great talk by Jimmy Bogart in I think it
was the same NDC I was low conference
that the Ian Cooper talk was in I think
it was so right I was like twenty
thirteen or twelve one of the two and he
had a really great quote that sums this
up for me really well the ultimate goal
here is to ship code it's not to write
tests tests are just a means to the end
of shipping code we can have a hundred
percent code coverage and no one use our
product or we can have zero percent code
coverage and we can be a millionaire
you know there's no correlation between
the two
okay so pragmatic testing kind of says
that we don't always have to write all
the tests that we've been writing
previously so what does that mean in
terms of when do we and how do we decide
whether to write your tests or not
I saw talk at test West a few years ago
by a lady called Sam Connelly who I
believe was working at Tyrell at the
time and she had a great talk on
deciding whether or not to write a UI
test and a very simple system for
helping you to make that decision um so
you can see it here it's really
straightforward she had a simple graph
on the y-axis he said what is going to
be the impact to our business if this
feature we are delivering breaks and
then on the x-axis he said how often is
his feature you're going to get used so
it's pretty easy for most features to
put them somewhere on that graph but the
really really clever part and it's such
a simple thing I wish I had thought of
this if she drew a couple of diagonal
lines down here and she said basically
if you're really far to the left ie
number four contact us much she's going
to happen to your business if the
contact Oz link is broken on your
website people can find it on Google or
somewhere else and it's probably not
going to happen that often because
people don't click on contact us as much
as they're going to exercise other
features in your application so don't
write a UI test for it it's okay it's a
test it's just gonna possibly be slow
hold you back be brittle you're gonna
spend time fixing it don't write it it's
not worth it
now as you start to move up this graph
towards the right-hand side and you pass
this threshold here then options
features 2 & 6 transfer funds and login
well look if you're a bank and transfer
funds is broken that's a huge impact to
your business right and that's going to
get used a lot as well so you probably
want to make sure that you've got some
decent UI tests around that because
they're going to give you more
confidence so it's a really really
simple idea for this sliding room to our
UI test or not yep so another thing that
we often think about in terms of how to
decide what kind of tests are on a right
is a concept that we call speed versus
confidence now in this context when we
say speed we mean you've got some sort
of tests wait how long does it take from
starting to run that test wait to when
that test suite finishes and then
confidence once you've finished
running their test suite how confident
are you that there is a bug in your code
or put another way how confident are you
to let your product owner click the
button to the play to production now if
we do some very scientific graphing of
this and we start with manual testing
and automated UI testing these exercise
the system on behalf of the user so they
give us a lot of confidence but they're
pretty slob mm-hmm yeah now in
comparison if we look at an
implementation focus test like the one
we had towards the very beginning of the
talk it's in process in memory takes a
few milliseconds to run it's really
really fast but the amount of confidence
it gives us is really low relatively
speaking because they're only testing a
little portion of the code and we're
often mocking our production
implementation details now if we take
one of those implementation tests we add
on some real database calls we've got
some outer process communication now so
we're an order of magnitude slower but
there's a whole class of errors that we
would now pick up you know is the ORM
mappings correct have our database
migrations put the schemer into a state
that actually works with our system you
know when we hydrate the objects back
does that work etc now if we start
graphing this we're sort of seeing that
there's an inversely proportional
relationship between speed and
confidence now why is this useful for
deciding how we test pretty much every
company these days is you know trying to
be devops and and all of that sort of
thing what we're trying to do is create
faster feedback loops we're trying to
get features out to our users faster and
faster so if we can come up with a
testing strategy that increases our
speed whilst giving us enough confidence
then obviously that's a good thing let's
explore this a little bit further we
have a hypothesis
that hypothesis is that you're not going
to deploy to production unless you make
some minimum level of confidence 100
percent yeah an often product owners
when you ask them what's the minimum
level of competence they're gonna say a
hundred percent however we challenge you
to set a minimum confidence level that's
actually as low as possible
now you might get laughed out of the
room for that but based on the last
slide what happens if we set a minimum
confidence level that's as long as
possible is we have a much
a feedback loop which means if there is
a problem and let's be honest 100
percent is obviously not possible there
is always bugs bugs in our code then
that means that it's even faster for us
to get fixes out for those bugs now what
we would then say is that you would
create a testing strategy that meets
this confidence level as fast as
possible so that we can realize this
sort of fast feedback loop dream but
then there's a really really important
point that's often missed in and from
what we've seen in testing strategies
and most companies which is you
shouldn't just set a testing strategy
and say job done off to the pub and
never look at it again we need to have
that continuous improvement mindset
that's so core to agile and DevOps and
we need to actually change our testing
strategy over time but we don't change
it willy-nilly we need to change it
based on hypotheses on data we need to
go and measure things like what's the
cycle time from an idea to that idea
getting in production or how many bugs
do we get in production when we release
our software and adjust our testing
strategy over time to make sure that we
improve them I think metrics light a
state of DevOps metrics can be really
useful here as you know industry
standard metrics so you not only you can
use to measure yourself but you can
actually compare yourself against other
organizations as well so I think that
was the you've got the lead time to
change so like how long from code commit
to getting something in the hands of the
customer you've got a value ray yeah how
does it take you to recover from that
and have to know you're deploying so
there's thousands of data points for
that way you could start sort of see and
measure yourself and this has all been
like statistically proven to match
against the businesses revenue stream
etc so they're great for very simple
metrics to derive and really powerful
getting definitely stations really good
stuff now when we kind of look at this
we actually had a bit of a realization
and it's a bit shocking to some people
but that first sort of step there that's
that's not a technical decision it's not
testers that should be deciding that
that's a business decision the amount of
confidence for each fixture that's
something a business person a product
owner should be deciding now sure once
they've made that decision then
obviously the testing strategy we come
up with to meet that confidence level is
a technical decision that hopefully not
just test as the testers and developers
working together closely are making and
then it's everyone's responsibility to
continuous
improve it should be a mindset that's
throughout the entire team but there's
one question that I'm assuming is in
some of your minds right now which is
that sounds great isn't that wonderful
theory that technical people and the
business people are going to talk
together and make a decision and you
know we're not gonna get told off for
writing tests rather than getting
features out as fast as we can yeah who
said that conversation in here where you
kind of go to a business person and say
oh we want to write some UI test for
this sorry we've got to ship yeah and
you get shut down
we need more features but we do have an
answer to this and it's something called
risk-based testing now let's look at
what respects testing is essentially
creating a risk based model that gives
us a common nomenclature to have
discussions between technical people and
business people about the risk on a per
feature basis once you've had this
discussion and you you come up with the
risk rating for a particular feature
then it makes sense to track it in your
task tracking system and the problem
here though I guess that we need to
solve is to have that conversation and
for it to be a meaningful conversation
that is easy to have to bridge the gap
between you know business people and the
technical people we need a clear way to
determine a rating so this is where we
can start to bring things which were
already quite often used in businesses
to start bridging that gap that sort of
language gap between the business and
the engineering departments so what
you're looking at here is a risk model
so a lot of you might work for companies
that already have these in place I work
for a bank
over in Western Australia and pretty
much we breathe by our risk models
they're so important to the function of
the bank so which is a great thing
because it means that everybody
understands these things now they're
quite often they're going to be laid out
in the terminology of your business the
one you're seeing here is is not ours
it's one that Rob and I grab from the
internet and everyday but let's have a
quick look at it so we've got a couple
of axes on the y-axis very
straightforward we've got a likelihood
so this is basically how likely is this
thing to happen is it is it going to
happen
so look at the top almost certain it's
going to often occur occur once
a week down the bottom it's rare
conceivable but only on extreme
circumstances once in a hundred years so
again it should be fairly
straightforward the business to start
working on risk rating for each of your
features because they already understand
this language looking along the top
we've got the consequences obvious this
was to happen so you can see this one is
kind of talking about injuries and
financial loss so it's possibly from a
kind of hospital realm or something like
that because on the far right hand side
we've got catastrophic risks could cause
death or massive financial loss so this
is pretty serious stuff on this rating
but the key here is that for every
feature you're going to start building
you want to have a conversation up front
which is going to involve product owners
stake holders testers developers and
enlist all the people basically that are
involved in delivering this feature to
put it somewhere inside this matrix so
let's say that we've got a feature where
it's possible that there could be a
moderate financial loss so it's going to
fall inside the moderate category so
that hopefully something if we can agree
with the business we can put that into
our tracking system that's now a given
so how are we going to use this to
decide how to test this item so this is
where we can drop into a really simple
model for risk based testing so Rob and
I flew this one together chuckles like
five minutes it's a starting point you
might already have one
but if not you know start with something
simple like this and then you can always
inspect it and adapt it as you're going
forward so if we take our medium base
risk it falls into the middle column
here so what this is telling us and this
will all be agreed upfront as part of
your testing methodology and strategies
is that you're gonna do a manual test of
this feature once it has been built so
that's a bit of like exploratory testing
just kind of have a once-over on it make
sure that it feels like it's hanging
together we're gonna have basic coverage
on the unit tests so we might have some
subcutaneous tests kind of behavior
level we're not worried about kind of
using more very advanced testing
techniques like fuzz testing or property
testing or things like that because it's
a fairly straightforward feature and
we're not going to have a UI test for it
because it doesn't warrant it based off
its risk rating now you can see for
something which is a critical risk we
actually have a lot more tests
going on for this so we're gonna
manually test it every single release
we're gonna have unit tests which
implement all sorts of testing over this
feature because it's incredibly
important this feature does not fail and
for our UI test we're not just going to
have a happy UI test but we're gonna
test all the negative runs through that
feature as well so that's going to be
obviously a lot more work in delivering
this feature and if we have this
formalized upfront we can take that into
our estimation sessions and we can
estimate the complexity of delivering
this item accordingly based off the
amount of testing that we have to do so
these are really powerful models it is
but and the beautiful thing is when you
start thinking about this you realize
this isn't actually just about testing
if you're working on a feature that's
like a critical feature you're going to
spend more time analyzing to understand
the thing in great detail you're going
to spend more time implementing and
doing defensive coding practices and
various other things and you're going to
spend more time testing it what this
means is that when you have this
conversation with your business
stakeholder and they decide this feature
is critical they know that that feature
is not going to take two days to
implement they know it's going to take
four weeks to implement and so they can
have a very you know very pragmatic
business conversation about how much
they want to invest in a particular
feature yeah
and you don't have these silly
situations where teams are writing you
know life-or-death software and being
given a lot of pressure to kind of cut
corners on features that they really
shouldn't cut corners on but on the same
token they have a clear path to for
something that doesn't really matter to
not really put any real effort in
awesome it's pretty cool that's great
the one other thing I'd say is that what
you would do like so a lot of big
companies will already have one of these
but if you don't what you need to do is
make sure that these are in terms that
are relevant to your company and your
business and you can be quite specific
some of the ones that I've seen have
specific financial amounts for these
like you know greater than two million
dollars of financial loss or you know
whatever it might be so we've built our
amazing feature we've nurtured it we
started from nothing we put it into
production done yeah move along happy
days
throw it over defend go to the pub go to
the pub it's good right unfortunately
not because really
I guess once we've put a feature into
production it's kind of like the end of
the beginning for that feature and now
it's into the rest of its life and
there's a lot of things that we have to
think about when it's in the real world
which I think all fall into kind of
similar testing categories so I want to
go through some things that I've kind of
come across in the last few years which
I think of really again changed the way
that I think about features in
production and DevOps and things like
that so I want to start with a concept
called behavior driven infrastructure so
can I get your hands in here for kind of
who's done this or has been using it or
has heard of it course we've got a few
people did this is this is brilliant I
love this so I work for a bank and we
have got extremely complicated security
architectures that we have to run within
to make sure that our organization is
compliant so these things normally would
be built by a team off to the side they
would go and set up all the networks for
you and you'll kind of have this
implicit trust that it's just working ok
but when it comes to actually ensuring
that that thing is compliant that the
network is still working how we gonna do
that
now BDI kind of turns the actual
building of that infrastructure onto its
head and says well what about if we
could express our infrastructure in
terms of BDD tests just like we can
express our application features so I'll
give you an example of that let's say
that we have a couple of subnets and
they are only allowed to talk to each
other over port 443 so you could
conceive abdi test that said given zone
Z 20 when I attempt to connect to zone z
21 over port 80 then the connection will
not be made so let's say we started off
with that so there are DSL zin really I
think it's r-spec or something which is
really great for expressing this kind of
test so if we're running against AWS or
as your we can put some code up there
that can actually check that real
network connection for us so that test
will start off red because there is no
network there's nothing there so let's
say we get our arm template and we build
a V net we've put two subnets inside it
they can talk to each other over many
many ports so that test is still going
to be red because that Connect
can get through and then what we do in
our arm template is we're gonna add some
sort of network rule to say now let's
start blocking off the ports from this
when we do that the test goes green so
we've used these tests to start to build
up these complex kind of architectures
and topologies and on premise in the
cloud wherever you need to put your
networks so they're great for helping us
build it but they have an added benefit
which is that because these tests are
actually running against the real
networks we can keep using them so once
that network is up and we're dropping
our applications into it we can
continuously run the tests against the
network to ensure that the compliance
hasn't been broken so they give us a
great way to kind of order it and make
sure that our networks are as they
should be so very very powerful so
people are writing software nowadays and
it's it's not a all-or-nothing
replacement when we put something into
production so I remember back in the day
we'd kind of just do a whole cutover of
everybody and that's really risky as
well that's really really dangerous we
don't know how the service is going to
scale in the real world is it going to
have a negative impact on other services
etc etc so if things like Bluegreen
deployments and canary deployments can
really help us here with testing our
software in the real world because we
can put something in the blue slot and
we can slowly move traffic onto it and
we can make sure that it's not having
adverse effects on other services which
are in the same kind of service
architecture of their testing and
production is awesome we're all building
micro services nowadays and it's
becoming increasingly difficult to
actually test these in an isolated
environment because there are so many of
them there are so many moving parts so
being able to test in production is
going to be a great asset if we can get
to that if we can have test accounts
test customers and we can continuously
ensure that our critical business
features are providing an adequate SLA
when they're running in the real
environment that's again a really really
powerful thing to be able to do so
nothing tells you that things are
working better than the testing
production who's her charity majors talk
I was fortunate enough to see her in
Perth a year or so ago and she has this
great phrase which is observability over
monitoring once you know probably got
that runway
that's nothing furiously at me so when
we're putting so many micro-services
into the real world now in cloud
environments we have to expect that the
environment is going to fail at some
point in time there's going to be
something which has got a degraded
service it's just not working
something's gone wrong up there now if
we're building micro services the way
that people like some Newman described
them then they should be autonomous
components right if your micro service
is going to go down the moment another
service goes down and just have this
huge knock-on effect then that's
obviously not going to be a great
architecture to be deploying but if your
micro services is autonomous and let's
say one of its services it depends on
goes down but it can still service a
query in a different way we've hit a
really weird state now because we have a
network where we have a bunch of
services some are up some are down yet
we're still providing the service back
through to the customer so it's really
important to stop maybe thinking about
our network as having to be entirely up
or else things are bad and start looking
in terms of what level of performance
are we actually providing through to our
users so we are certain that we're
always providing them a service and that
could be with things being down or up
and the last one I'll pick on here is
just magic number testing so this is a
really interesting one so is anyone ever
integrated with a payment provider like
stripe right cool so they have these
great kind of ideas where they will give
you a set of credit card numbers our
customer IDs and the different numbers
will respond in different ways so one of
them might respond with overdrawn one of
them might respond with the account is
locked so a magic number testing give us
a way to be able to I guess put up a
service and then allow others to test
against it by using well known
transaction numbers so they can test all
the failure states that could come back
from this other service without having
to set up data in specific ways and jump
through hoops like that so again really
powerful techniques to help us testing
and especially when we're in production
environments to absolutely now this is
this is a quite a small list the the
actual things that you might need to do
in terms of testing after you deploy to
production is actually
enormous and there's a really good slide
on Rob Crowley's talk yesterday on
service meshes that I highly recommend
you check out that had a really really
extensive list of things but while we
were coming up with this list here we
kind of observed a little bit of a
pattern between them I've got things
like testing and production
observability over monitoring and things
like synthetic transactions and all of
them are designed to work well in that
sort of micro-services type architecture
where our deployments are much more
dynamic than they were traditionally
traditionally you deploy one thing it's
either up or down
it's pretty straightforward but in this
sort of new new architectural panacea
that we have now everything's a lot more
dynamic and I guess the the final
thought that we wanted to leave everyone
with is out of all the patterns that
you're using now and the practices that
you're using which ones are going to
need to evolve you know as well as the
ones that we've already talked about to
help us in the future thank you so we're
good about 8 to 10 minutes so question
time so ok that one with the UI testing
patterns on it so just to repeat that so
Sam Connolly is based in Sydney and
she's often for any company to run that
talk that we referenced over a lunch
time brown bag very cool she's pretty
responsive on Twitter she's been
tweeting the last few days so it's
probably the easiest way to find her
any other questions no that was a
question but that's alright I'll let you
off yeah
[Music]
yes that's a good point I was actually
in some of the rehearsals I casually
dropped in to rob a question about how
long those tests take when they're
spinning up the database and and you're
right they do definitely take longer to
do my experience was it because I was
testing classes in collaboration as
opposed to testing individuals and
mocking everything out I actually had a
lot less tests than if I was testing at
a very low sort of isolated unit level
but it was a trade-off and there were
certain operations where I looked to
actually go for a more like ports an
adapter style architecture and just try
and isolate the database component from
it and I guess if you had Rob's graph
where you have that diagonal line maybe
that's one that kind of sits between the
unit tests and the subcutaneous tests of
the database is where you're still doing
behavioral tests but you're trying to
isolate those slower components out I
think I mean my experience has been I
used to run on like eight threads in
parallel and each would have its own
local DB and they'd be taking about like
Noor point one or two of a second - yeah
because I wasn't rebuilding the database
every time I was using libraries like
jimmy-boy guards respawn to take the
database back to a well-known state and
and that always appeared to be a lot
faster than building from scratch each
time but and there's definitely a few
tricks you can do to try and speed them
up but if you are I know I think they're
great tests because exercise in the
database actually really does give you a
lot of confidence but if you're finally
at it is taken too long maybe you could
start looking at replacements like
in-memory AF cores got the in-memory
provider for example so yeah I mean I'd
say most most small to medium sized
applications like even if you have like
a thousand or two of those sorts of
tests still like only a couple of
minutes it's running four and that's
that's mostly what we've seen if you've
got something enormous well you know
either you want to start breaking it up
or sure maybe in that case that is too
slow for your feedback loop and you want
to mock them out and knowing the
trade-off of a lower amount of
confidence
but a faster sort of release and that's
kind of where our pragmatic testing
thing comes into play right because it's
saying don't just do subcutaneous test
not like including the database because
we said it do what makes sense in your
context per feature any other question
question yeah so there's a all the way
back almost almost so that link there
it's a blog post that I wrote a few
years back it's actually a review of
Jimmy Bo guards holistic testing thing
but I've got a lot of content in there
talking about like subcutaneous tests
and those sorts of things and so there's
there's some coverage in there around
this but essentially what we found is
that there's certain patterns that make
it a lot easier to understand where
problems are so we kind of saw a little
bit of that actually you know pair
programming yeah no not here sorry where
was it RNA was this one this one so
things like this here where we're using
in our case we use beta fiber like
splitting things up in two different
methods using like a BDD syntax can be
helpful because then you'll know like
which one of those it was in and so you
immediately know where to look obviously
if it's here then you know it's it's
sort of somewhere in your in your stack
but that's where typically you know
you'll see the exception you'll see a
line number you click through and you
kind of get to where the problem is most
of the time to be honest haven't found
it to be too much of a problem but yeah
I mean look there's a slight trade-off
there right like it might be you know
there's a few more classes you're
testing it might be a little bit harder
to quickly find it but typically with
things like this I've found such a
pretty decent other questions
top cool thank you thank you for coming
everybody
[Applause]